[Music]
be
rencontrez damien il est un employé fictif
chez optimi management une société de gestion de patrimoine
de new york
mais damien n'est pas à new york il travaille
avec nous
et il passe des appels du canada à
montréal
il contacte des agents immobiliers  réserver des visites
avec des courtiers
au nom d'un client étranger qui
veut acheter une propriété à montréal
son client tom bernard est aussi un
personnage fictif
joué par quelqu'un d'autre qui travaille
pour nous
tom a la soixantaine il visitera des
propriétés avec melissa ses 20 ans  -quelque chose d'
intérêt amoureux
melisa fait également partie de notre équipe et se fait
passer pour une étudiante de l'université mcgill
tom veut lui acheter un condo qui coûterait
au moins un million de dollars mais il y a
une
tournure encore plus surprenante dans notre
configuration
[Musique]
étranger plus  les prochains jours,
tom fait le tour de la ville pour trouver des propriétés
avec son argent sale en
visitant des maisons de rêve et des condos de luxe en
discutant affaires avec cinq courtiers choisis au hasard
comment vont-ils réagir
[Musique]
mardi 18 février tom et melissa
quittent radio canada accompagnés de notre
producteur
qui se fera passer pour l'assistant personnel de tom
tout le monde porte un équipement de caméra cachée
ils partent pour participer à cette
expérience de trois jours
[musique]
leur agent de new york leur a réservé des visites
dans des propriétés avec  étiquettes de prix que la
plupart des gens ne peuvent pas se permettre,
ils visiteront cinq adresses
de luxe allant des tours de condos modernes du centre-ville
au vieux montréal
et jusqu'au sommet de westmouth
me
certains appartements ont des vues à couper le souffle
tandis que d'autres présentent des intérieurs somptueux
le travail du courtier n'est pas seulement de leur faire visiter
ils ont également l'obligation légale de signaler les
tentatives de blanchiment d'argent
et d'autres activités suspectes
c'est exactement ce que tom veut tester
oui monsieur tom est sur le point de dire très clairement
aux courtiers
comment il a fait grossir son argent d'
accord c'est l'
un des courtiers semble méfiant  après avoir
entendu cette divulgation complète, d'
accord,
les quatre autres courtiers n'ont aucune
réserve,
c'est tout le contraire que
nous montrons  a envoyé nos images à des experts,
donc
pour cet expert qui enseigne aux agents immobiliers
comment se conformer à la loi,
un cas comme celui-ci doit être signalé
kathleen
si l'affaire avait été conclue, les courtiers
auraient pu faire face à
des accusations criminelles
étrangères
une semaine après notre opération de piqûre, nous avons
appelé le  courtiers
de poser cette question
personnellement
[Musique]
quatre des cinq courtiers ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient été témoins
d'aucune tentative récente de blanchiment d'
argent
nous leur avons ensuite dit la vérité sur
bernard
au moment de notre appel aucun des
courtiers n'avait
déposé d'activité suspecte  rapporter qu'ils ont
tous affirmé avoir agi
conformément à leurs obligations légales
est
[Musique]
je dois faire preuve de diligence raisonnable je
vais en fait écrire l'offre mais je
n'ai jamais écrit d'offre
nous avons également montré nos images à osic l'
autorégulation  l'organisme
qui supervise les réponses des courtiers immobiliers
est
étranger
revenons à notre opération de piqûre nos
courtiers
ne semblent pas s'inquiéter de faire des affaires
impliquant de l'argent sale
notre personnage douteux w  fourmis quelque chose
d'autre des agents immobiliers
il ne veut pas que son nom apparaisse
nulle part dans les documents
l'achat sera effectué par l'intermédiaire d'une
société sous le nom de melisa
problème
[Musique]
euh
si les courtiers ne signalent pas d'activité suspecte
à ce stade, il le fera  être presque
impossible à détecter plus tard
bfa
nous avons décidé de pousser notre expérience un
peu plus loin
nous avons demandé aux courtiers une deuxième visite
[Musique]
tous ont accepté de se revoir
tom leur fait savoir
qu'il est prêt à procéder à une
offre formelle d'
accord
étranger d'
accord c'est ça même le courtier qui
semblait prudent lors de la première visite
a maintenant toute la documentation pré-
remplie afin de procéder à la transaction
[Musique]
n'est pas là même si c'est elle
qui est censée signer le
document d'achat formel
tous les courtiers vérifient l'identité de melisa en
utilisant des photocopies de ses pièces d'identité avec photo
[Musique]
étonnamment, la loi permet aux courtiers de
conclure
des transactions immobilières aussi douteuses
tant qu'ils déposent
une plainte  rapport d'activité piquant par la suite,
certains de nos courtiers ont fait valoir qu'ils l'
auraient fait
dans ce cas, le comptoir des taxes,
mais il est peu probable que le signalement après coup
ait aidé les forces de l'ordre à
attraper les blanchisseurs d'argent dans ce cas,
les courtiers n'ont pas d'identité avec photo pour  tom
et une photocopie facilement falsifiable pour melisa
c'est
[Musique]
l'agent inscripteur accompagne son courtier junior
jusqu'à la propriété la plus chère d'une valeur de
près de sept millions de dollars
il prend l'initiative de conclure l'affaire
[Musique]
le courtier principal n'a jamais remis en question les motivations de tom
ni  son identité, nous avons pris contact et
demandé un
il prétend que son collègue ne lui a jamais
parlé des transactions de trafic de drogue de tom
la deuxième visite n'aurait jamais dû avoir
lieu
[musique]
ces courtiers ont été les premiers à nous envoyer des
documents
dans l'espoir de conclure la transaction à la
fin
nous  reçu trois de ces propositions
et réveiller
une archive